ah no big dink
it starts out for the noggin
welcome back to the Julian podcast we
were away for such a long time it's been
84 years we back thank you for joining
us this week we have a special guest her
name is nobody we don't have a guest
thank you for a loop there didn't I Wow
you checked our audience into thinking
we have a guest
sometimes you gotta keep monitor on
their toes I see you falling on your
heels you need to stay on the toes this
episode is brought to you by cool what
Equipe is the toothbrush from the future
comes to your house in a little package
like this and they ship you new bristle
tips on a subscription basis every month
so you're not brushing your teeth with a
low standard crappy manual toothbrush
and you're also not spending a ton of
money on an over print hello on an
overpriced electric toothbrush go to get
quip that's GE tqu IP comm /o - Julian
and get your first refill pack free with
equip electric toothbrush check it out
guys also the skin shouts out to our
girl Karen who made a video about my
sponsor reads on the skin because we
were pretty much just a costume you but
um the skin is a newsletter that goes to
your email every day it's completely
free and it gives you all the
information you need about what's going
on in the world in a really nice format
that's easy to read easy to digest okay
all the stuff you need to hear about
it's in the skin newsletter in your
email so you don't have to look for it
in ridiculous convoluted environments
online is he licking your arm go to this
game that's tes ki mmm that's two M's
comm slash Jenna Julianne subscribe it's
free it's completely free supports the
podcast and you're entered to win a $250
Visa gift card new god dude he really
likes licking you it actually is this is
my every night layer of hell where he
just
we love each other it's just my hand not
a little Oh what you can't lick my hand
you can like whatever he wants and he
does whatever this looks like probably
the bottom alright Julian are you ready
for this no no not so if a lot of you
guys remember we did a movie theme songs
or you know famous songs from movies
podcast where I compiled a list and
Julian had to guess and a lot of you
guys suggested that we do that again
with TV show theme song so feel free to
play along at home while you're enjoying
yourself this I just want you guys to
know in case anyone in the comments
feels like being like you didn't include
this show this could be hours long like
there are so many TV shows with so many
songs like just going through like
looking on YouTube it was like I could
have made this list a billion like
there's just so many but in my brain
this is about as long as it gets
because I only know this many shows well
okay so to be fair I tried to mix in
there's probably some stuff in here that
you don't know they're like more classic
television like a bunch of different
shows I tried to like make a little bit
of a spectrum while also putting in one
specifically for you Julie oh is it
Breaking Bad what sorry okay terms not
gonna cut it out Julie are you excited
I'm excited no yelling at me if I get
suffering I'm not I'm not yeah and guys
Julian was born in 1992 so if he doesn't
know a classic television show please
take it easy I also know these kids be
like I'm like I didn't know I know a
couple of things that you watched
growing up but like I didn't really know
what you watched growing up so I
couldn't like include that like I also I
don't know no I older than you I think
you probably did a good job I'm gonna
give you an 8 out of 10 preemptively
we'll see if you can reach that alright
well give it a listen let people at home
try and hear it too so just blurt it out
as I think you can if you want
we're yeah so we're gonna be solid
guests yeah yeah well give you guys a
pause so if you're playing at home you
uh you can do as mediocre as me but you
know also I think you're gonna do okay
I tried to make sure that you weren't
gonna get down on yourself okay I strive
for okay
I also realized that a lot of the like
cartoons and kid songs and stuff that I
grew up with all have the name of the
show in them all of them I'm ready
like what did that start I can do this I
think that's a Mandela effect thing I
think they added the nachos in like you
know really yeah yeah
what all right are you ready don't you
are you ready I was born okay I'm ready
yeah here's your first I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
this even start with dr. fellow
[Music]
I won't even get excited about your life
let's get it camera four let's go what
else would you say I don't know some
other inspirational things The Drew
Carey Show it's dr. Phil one for one
good batting a thousand as they say that
was the right way to start this off yeah
I think so I think yeah I just wanted to
keep this entertaining for those of you
that are both younger and older than us
that's awfully old we'll see here this
is also for you doing hey yes yes Patti
meet my millionaires
it's millionaire matchmaker with Patti
Stanger Wow don't get staying by her
Stanger Wow okay that's such a good show
it's such a good like reality show it is
just like plop on we've been watching
like every episode of it so you're a
rewatch fan then our reality shows yeah
sometimes I'm rewashing Breaking Bad
right now I'm um
probably my fourth or fifth three what
No yeah really enjoying it right is it
gonna happen different I like the use of
framing and what okay are you ready go
use your next one
[Music]
why is there
[Applause]
[Music]
this is likes this is sci-fi but kind of
sexy
[Music]
CSI Miami well I mean you just gave me a
really no face so maybe I'll try it
again
see you sign Las Vegas Las Vegas just
the Las Vegas the show no starting Josh
Duhamel Duhamel do you hate on YouTube
yeah no that's not it um this show I'll
give you a hint
the show was popular like in the 90s
like when I was a kid I know it is what
x-files you're kind of close you're on
the right path it was like I think it
was on like network TV like sort of at
night and it was about um let's say
there enigmas that haven't been resolved
cold-case no I thought I'd had it with
that one unsolved mysteries yeah yeah
great thank you for helping me out a
little bit with that one
you welcome that's a great show I like
that show honestly I think season two is
you know Julian not as [__] strong all
right are you ready yeah you should go
back and watch some of it I've put it on
the TV for you before but you fell
asleep yeah cause it's nighttime
give it a second I'll give it a sec
like motorbikes and monster trucks
oh to be a love interest
oh it's powering okay that's not even
the same song that's so naughty it's
like to anyone who knows the rest of the
power ranger song didn't not just that
gogo high ranges I applaud you because I
don't even I was thinking that no I'm
not even gonna say okay here's your next
one okay CatDog no it's at South Park oh
my god oh my god I'm sorry I'm sorry a
for blurting it up for saying cat tiger
in itself no no let's rewind I was a
great show I didn't know that you were
like old enough to watch a lot cat dog
it was [__] good man how dark is good
see I didn't want to include too much of
that like in here's I didn't know how
old you were like I loved all that [__]
like Rocko's Modern Life and stuff let
me look up the theme song - cat dog yeah
I bet I could sing along with it okay
let's see CatDog CatDog
[Music]
I like this here just kidding for those
of you that don't know what to hat dog
is again I apologize to those of you
living in other countries that maybe
didn't have any of these shows it's
probably not a very fun podcast for you
to listen to but cat dog was a cartoon
show about a cat and a dog that share a
body so they get one end there's a cat
and the other end there's a dog and
they're just connected by this orange
they go on some crazy advantages they go
on a lot of adventures this that was a
great show
I think that might have been Tom Kenny
the I did spongebob I'm not sure I
cannot believe that you thought well I
wasn't I mean I watched South Park as a
kid obviously because like I had five
brothers and sisters and they all
watched it and I was just like watching
it but yeah that that first note somehow
it's just like yes cat dog yeah I'll try
not to blurt it outside I just get
excited
[Music]
this is it Sesame's Transnistria is it
early in Burt visit Elmo wait is it
Barney you're digging yourself in a hole
here
[Music]
you're repeatedly saying the
neighborhood shuffle no not hard
[Music]
baby I don't hear any repeating of the
show name wait what I would watch how do
you let me ask you question do you know
who Jim Henson is know I've heard that
name Julian are you messing with no what
the heck is a Jim Henson I've never
heard of him I swear to God who is he
well who's Jim Henson let's start there
no it's either gonna jog your memory or
it's not okay all right I don't know who
he is I don't know what that's that song
was have you ever heard of the Muppets
oh yeah I have heard of the Muppets
definitely heard the Muppets Muppet
Babies I was half right got the baby's
part I think Sesame Street's like an O
okay guess or something that they sound
sort of similar I didn't watch the
Muppets I know that was that's too old
for you it's Jim Henson the guy who
created the Muppets yeah he did a good
job yes he did I mean um well now I'm
second-guessing myself or was he may be
one of them I'm almost positive let me
look it up yeah you create the Muppets
ooh
born on September 24th that he of Virgo
other he is mmm that's a late burger II
don't think he's a very girl oh yeah
maybe right all right you ready yeah
who's your next one
I know what it is I had the coffee I
know it three-two-one jeopardy I give
you the countdown so I didn't spoil it
this is a 10-hour version of this song
by those guys there this 1.8 million I
love that people probably have used that
for so many good things absolutely
I love them all right I I know for sure
that you do not know the answer to this
but this is for all of my nostalgic
little kids watch me born in the 80s
watch me get this [__] dude what are we
doing right the name of it in it
[Music]
No what's your guess
lamb chops yeah we're gonna Shari Lewis
and she's like a puppeteer and that
white lamb chops not a puppet thank you
I loved lamb chops lamb chops sounds
like a fun time it was so good is a
great show like I sometimes go back and
watch stuff from lamb chops on YouTube
and it makes me like want to cry it's so
pure mm-hmm amazing
sorry okay that was for our audience
okay yeah no that's all good
hey you know Julie you got that good job
spooky
[Applause]
ah this is recent
[Music]
think there you go there he go thinking
we just watch this
[Music]
[__] why am I not getting it I know this
like that
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm pissed that I'm not kidding this
would you like me to paint an image for
you that might help you
making a murderer no ok paint an image
think about someone riding on a horse
west rope yes
[__] dude we have any watch these into
by the way no we got to watch it's all
done we're season three
we haven't watched the most repellant
damn well Julian wanted to wait because
he didn't want like to watch one at a
time
yeah one bit yeah but then we were gonna
like download them for our plane to Hong
Kong and we couldn't okay [__] I just
said making him work dude I'm not gonna
live that down
dammit ok it's ok don't know alright
it's no use you're next
[Music]
you are absolutely not alive in their
joking
Mickey Mouse
it's like the worst is over Tommy did
not tell me what is it
and we'd be all in there a camera I used
to watch this all the time on Nick at
night it was a show called bewitched
bewitched I've heard the name bewitched
I didn't know I was a TV show it was a
great show
she was like a witch slash genie or
whatever and her mom was a genie and
well the whole banter was like there's a
lot I don't what what's the matter
I don't know if that's I don't think
that's bewitched I Dream of Jeannie was
also one of the ones that had the same
there's no B which is not alright if you
think it's B which don't let you I'll
let you think okay ego here's your next
one okay
I knew I had to wait for it I knew it is
coming this is the wonderful poison
singing rock of love with Bret Michaels
oh yeah what a gem good answer Julian
thank you thank you
oh god what a show what a show Jesus
Christ that show is so funny okay can I
go can I go can I go no yes recently met
a person named Poe and I was like oh
yeah yeah I was a Teletubby with least
once for all the way and I think I think
everyone was I wasn't intelligent it
came out like by the time I was like
babysitting I think so be a Teletubby as
a 16 year old oh yeah here's your next
one
what's she saying it
do you wanna be a rock truck that's my
I think you've only seen a couple of
seasons of this show is this the one
with Nick Lachey the one where he's with
just difference in their living yeah
this is the intro to the newlyweds
I loved the newlyweds careful how you
talk about that show um let me keep you
guessing it sounds like a like a rock
star competition show so you want to be
a rock star right she's not saying rock
star she's saying do you wanna be on top
Tyra Banks yeah is America's Next Top
Model
oh my god I got it good job you've only
watched a couple of seasons of that yeah
I don't want antastic I prefer Project
Runway thousand times more than that
show Project Runway is one of my
favorite
[Music]
but what can you like that
that [__] bells end there oh yeah oh
my god hit that Bell
when I was what's your hit sir this song
isn't gonna change it's just gonna keep
going sometimes you just need it to keep
like jogging your memory
this isn't embarrassing one I actually
know that this one's embarrassing cuz
you've got me on this one before in
front of other people
you've gone in it wait
then another noon and me didn't a minute
diddly didn't in it's not Power Rangers
we already did that one but it's similar
[Music]
can you me like an easy hit like a
really not great hints like very big hmm
know your role that's pretty big one
that you would know your row Jubilee
mm-hmm I did I still don't know I just
Merman who is Jubilee I don't I just
remember you said that in one of your
videos you've never heard of Jubilee
that is a lie
alright I'll give you a better hint oh
wait he's a [__] magician looking for a
group of friends x-men yes I knew it was
embarrassing
alright I'm ready it hurts me below I
never watched it well that was the
cartoon version yeah the only cartoon
cartoon superhero shows I watched was
Teen Titans that was on like Saturday
morning cartoons I didn't know that
someone doesn't know their boo
[Music]
I Love Lucy yeah I'm so glad you got
that Lucille Ball yeah they really be
out there like holding an infant baby
and chase smoking a cigarette that's
that's not good for you Wilde all right
love that show here you go okay I'm
gonna take this opportunity to talk
about some sponsors because I'm not
answering these questions this episode
is brought to you by the quip is the
electric toothbrush it looks like it was
designed by Apple it's small enough to
fit in the palm of your hand and it
doesn't have the high price that all
other electric toothbrushes have okay
that's just the right amount of
vibrations into an ultra slim design
guiding pulses to help simplify better
brushing at a fraction of the cost of
the big stupid old brushes you know need
those plus there's no cluttering up your
bathroom quip comes with a mount that
goes right on your mirror so it also
doubles as a travel cover it's really
nice it literally looks like ice like a
space toothbrush is really awesome and
every month you can have a subscription
plan that they offer where they deliver
new brush heads like this okay because
your old brush heads they get used and
they get worn down and you're not
getting the best brush you can so quit
makes it so you're always getting the
best brush okay on a dentist recommended
three-month schedule for just $5 and
that includes free shipping so if you're
curious about qyp which i think you
should try it if you should sign up for
quick right now going equip that's get
quit that's GE tqu yp.com slash
annejulien you'll not only get started
with this awesome new toothbrush but
you're gonna get your first refill prac
pact for free it's got a toothbrush it's
got the bristle head for free okay if
you sign up using that URL you get a leg
up and you might really like it I think
I think you will enjoy it if you're
frustrated if you use a manual
toothbrush it's not that expensive
I was gonna make a lot of difference and
your breath will smell good some people
will like you check it out go to get
quip coms lost energy also the skin guys
it's a newsletter that provides you with
all of the awesome and terrible things
that are happening in the world but you
need to know them regardless the news is
a crazy thing and the news cycle can get
really convoluted especially with social
media nowadays and the skin doesn't
doesn't put up with any of that okay
they condense what's going on in the
world today you know a nice newsletter
so you can read it in your email inbox
every morning while you're drinking your
coffee or tea or pre-workout or water or
almond milk or smoothie or what else do
people drink in the morning protein
shake or cold coffee cold brew if you
like cold brew I personally like cold
brew I like making my own cold brew with
a French press we started the night
before you grinding the beans and you
mix it up and then you just leave it in
the cold press make sure you cover it in
the fridge and then nine hours is
probably the minimum I would say before
I would press it then when you press it
it's super smooth it doesn't have that
bite that normal hot coffee does you can
drink whenever you're drinking your
check out this game guys it's an awesome
newsletter I think you'll really enjoy
the way that they lay out their
newsletter it's not it's like very
simple and I like it gives you what you
need in the amount of times can go
dominate your conversations at work
about what's going on the world the
water cooler with Karen you have
something to say to Karen no oh you're
done saying [__] you to Karen because
she responded you got called out guys go
to the skin that's th es ki mmm that's
two M's calm / Jenna Julian sign up it's
completely free we'd appreciate it and
your enter doing the $250 Visa gift card
in the process
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors
you're a troll right now here's your
next one you okay I'm ready it hasn't
started yet
hi I'm captain I can't hear you hi Kathy
Oh
lives in a pineapple under the sea
spongebob squarepants absorbent and
yellow and porous is he this is the only
one I can sing the whole thing I told
you the story about how my dad was
friends with Batman and Batman came to
my party don't want him but did I tell
you that my dad is good friends with Tom
Kenny who boy Sponge Bob and he recorded
me a CD I know it's really it's like a
happy birthday from Sponge Bob
legitimately like I would die alright
alright batting a thousand still
[Music]
we're gonna say it
Sex in the City this just sounds like
something that would fit that tone it's
a show okay
that was popular in the 90s is it a very
young it's not a cartoon
it's about love though no it's not it's
about a family Brady Bunch
you know that was this is the Brady
Bunch The Brady Bunch pop pop pop up
that's the Brady Bunch son and they're
matters family matters yes I thought I
was Sex in the City I don't know just
felt like a good shot in the dark to
take sometimes you had to take them
that's enough why didn't know you need
to give you this come on in of you just
listening to the Breaking Bad theme song
what is it
I already said it Breaking Bad did you
put did you put Breaking Bad on the list
cuz you like that show is that why
mm-hmm
sidenote not joking at all sometimes
when I want to hear like no [__] me
[Music]
Brady Bunch
we compared ourselves to the Brady Bunch
when we were that's really cute
we even made that like nine picture
thing have you seen I should find it and
then I can tweet it
you absolutely should find it okay no
fine yep
[Music]
hello it's ringing a bell I just can't
is it a newer show dude I knew it you
might watch it if you have Netflix is it
making a murderer I was just joking I
was just calling back we've watched this
right mm-hmm
we actually circus know watched it a lot
while we were in Hong Kong oh this is
chef's table yeah wait I didn't get to
the part yet did it keepo oh it already
got to the part I really like chef's
table oh it's really good yeah I don't
know why chef's table it's very good
it's some of the most like well filmed
Food Show ever see I mean it's like the
civet ography is off the charts you
don't even have to be like interested in
food in order to really appreciate that
show wasn't in love with the desert
season I will say that ooh
tea you ready for you next yeah
[Music]
don't look at me like that you're
messing with my head
this was a show that was on I think
before you were like I know I know this
show hundred Oh cuz this rug that yeah
yeah I watched Rugrats it was a great
show did you like the Rugrats I did so I
had like a hierarchy of shows I would
watch on like Nick and it would be like
spongebob like rocket power and Rugrats
was like been third it wasn't huge but I
liked it I watched yeah was right Rock
power was on Nick right or was it on
something I think it was
[Music]
is it clean again I know it's I know
this like okay wait actually don't play
it hold on I need to block all sounds
out I can't believe this is blanking
this is where the bright lights and
Jenna's face leg starts to faze me and
I've watched this show a million hours
and I can't even play again sorry the
link that I put in there is bad so I
have to look it up
[Music]
oh it's Silicon Valley [__] I will I
almost [__] up a fairy woulda got this
yeah what an iconic song wouldn't iconic
intro sequence where they changed what
he was writing on the chalkboard every
time Simpson's good you're welcome
here's your next one
[Music]
Alvin and the Chipmunks oh I like them
thought they were silly okay what I
don't know I never watch are they
failing
[Music]
that's aggressive stop it knock it off
what is this you can't end it like that
God parson driver that's actually like
that's like one so when i rewatch it cuz
i'll rewatch things that i've seen
before
some are like goofy mindless that i want
background noise while i'm doing
something else and someone like
rewatching like breaking bad him like
rewatching but like i'll read watch the
office from x knowledge re-watch Parks
and Rec that's one of the intros that I
will literally never skip this is such a
good interest and it's quick too okay
[Music]
is it that's pretty good I honestly
couldn't tell you it's alright oh yeah
that one's like ingrained in my DNA at
this point like that the horn at the
beginning and they've changed that intro
a bunch of times like tweaked it but
I've seen every episode of every season
of Survivor mm-hmm shots how John
Cochran one of the best television shows
ever hmm it's gotten better with age
like fine wine
[Music]
x-files okay
the mean that will live on forever kill
you what a gym vision ace
Cheers it is not Cheers literally no
second guesses
Freaks and Geeks family ties there's a
show called step by step do you ever
watch that no it's too bad it's really
not a great show probably really not
about two families that had kids a lot
like your family got married and now
there's like a bajillion kids it was a
great show and I got an iconic intro
song loved it loved stuff do they make
that song for the shoulder they just
stumble upon gold okay cuz I've heard
that song Oh what what is it now this is
the story all about how my life got
flipped turned upside down I would like
to take a minute just sit right there
tell you how I became the Prince of a
town called bel-air Prince of bel-air
Fresh Prince of bel-air nice job i watch
that show too I did I was starting the
youtuber Will Smith right youtuber yeah
Oh Lucy stop what what do you know what
this song is you gonna see how funny
that is
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
do you want me to help you wait is it
getting there or is they've already got
there where did they come from when will
they come back they line
I don't know it's about otherworldly
beings Oh ancient aliens yes [__] outta
here
well now I need that song with
Evanescence over it can you play it play
both them at the same time cue em up I
can feel it one if you want wait but I
need to get know I need to get to the
vocal part of Evanescence and play it at
the beginning of this fair enough fair
enough
I'll riff so what's up its new album let
me get two right wouldn't you start
singing you can't argue that that didn't
sound like summer all right are you all
ready
yeah can I sing along too huh just give
me a second I can't hear I think that's
good enough yeah hey okay hold on
how can I pop this up there we go pop it
up pop it up ready oh it's gonna be
difficult to get them both going at the
same time wait
[Music]
this one's off a little I can't fix it I
don't know what I've done
[Music]
this is fits together so well it sounds
like just Evanescence why don't you add
the other side
your blood
[Applause]
when are you gonna add the other song or
you're getting flagged for copyright on
this one
[Music]
all right that's so more than enough of
that I'm so sorry
Wow oh boy I was not ready for that move
on we have a lot left yeah [__] let's
speed through him I was trying to sorry
prophet yeah
great show great show great show it's
called the Prophet with Marcus lemonis
Marcus lemonis Marcus lemonis that's
gonna call models when he barks you too
Calvin parka slow mode
[Music]
I would be shocked if you've ever seen
an episode of this
[Music]
space sci-fi no [__] clip 19 I guess
Magic School Bus
cheers I don't know
it's called Fraggle Rock Fraggle Rock it
was since you didn't get the Muppets
Fraggle Rock is a little difficult to
get but nailed it I also don't know if
you've ever seen this show
[Music]
[Applause]
nope no clue resigning Nickelodeon I
think it was a shell called salute your
shorts about kids being a camp Jesus
Christ a great show and that is an
amazing song you should watch it
sometime on our dress for you at the gym
out for a sec first nice work by the way
I found a way it's gonna take some time
[Music]
[Applause]
rusty on those lyrics I've met him
before he's what was that
drinking drugs nice josh is wonderful at
metric mm-hmm
Wow just less wonderful Game of Thrones
[Music]
how many times have you danced to this
probably on the internet always dance to
that comes on I just have to get up you
know yeah I don't know if you've ever
seen this show is this the one with the
werewolves
no idea do I love him I don't know I'm
trying to get you to the show oh it was
a game show for like young kids on
Nickelodeon it wasn't double dare or
guts but does the name Olmec ring any
bells there's a person Oh No
is it a person's the legends of the
Hidden Temple Oh nope okay it's got
nothing
hopefully those of you in the comments
enjoyed that I also don't know if you
ever seen this show
I have seen the show I've heard this
[Music]
these families I love you looked up from
your mic like you just thought of it I
did good job
Thanks well done Adams family got it get
crazy get loud get wild get party get
busy sir we have to catch up on the
family vacation and we haven't even
follow them
I got it before they said down to zero
yeah yeah right this might be a little
difficult we can do it
that's it
black mirror yes good job Julie great
show
[Music]
Tanny the TV show Annie the Magic School
Bus Sister Sister when's the power they
say sister sister oh gee what a great
song let's sesame street that was nice
yeah did you hear the part they said can
you tell me how to get to that how did
you not hear that here Julian this is
for you this is this is are they doing I
think good one of them just had a baby
or a second baby what is it this is like
one of my all-time favorite TV shows Zac
stone is gonna be saying this Plateau
Burnham
we've talked about this on the podcast
right we have it up here underrated like
way better way too good for its time
mm-hmm I won't agree well we should
rewatch yeah it's really funny and all
the intros are different
[Music]
gonna be this way
wait let it play
[Music]
I'll be there for you I'll be there for
you cause you're there for me to show
title what is it that's unrelated to I
know this so oh wait wait hold on hold
on I got it is this saved by the get
what's a hint oh group of friends oh
that's from friends best friends I knew
it was a really famous one
do you watch friends I not really
missing a lot of it but I didn't watch
it like in order every season
[Music]
[Applause]
the Jetson
yeah yeah hate is life true that vine
yeah I think you show me that I've never
watched the Jetsons huh
I think it's a it's actually a YouTube
video think from CollegeHumor and you
should look it up if your wife here yeah
I think I forget what it's called but
it's like me George Jetson hates his
wife and then it just keeps going
downhill it's fantastic great Family Guy
well done Julie I hope you know this
[Music]
oh is it jock tails yeah
I was gearing up for something different
what were you doing up or tell us this
Scooby Doo
cuz they said mysteries
Sartain yeah it's nice it's a great show
everything that I'm saying it's just
it's a great show cuz they are there
always shows or else you wouldn't
remember their theme song huh is this
scooby-doo I was just really it was like
Inception I had just thought it was
there but it wasn't quite yet yeah okay
[Music]
the leftovers oh my god I love that
China song is like haunting this is the
I think the best version are like the
most recognizable version I could find
for you and try to get the shells it
does this one might be difficult to get
summer high tide you got it oh my god
Julie mr. G
[__] you missed [__] you me
I didn't say [__] you said puck you with
the peas we're trying to have a
relationship with me yes oh my god all
right
[Music]
why are you looking at us thinking I
don't know what I don't know where
there's no idea
[Music]
you go everywhere
this is Saved by the Bell goddamnit
Suite Life of Zack and Cody yes is it no
it's starring Airy Kate and Ashley the
Olsen twins yes um what was their show
Oh
full house yeah good job man
Airy Kate and Ashley I grew up with them
Dave Coulier son
oh that's cool sorry yeah we're checking
across our universe Cooper card in a
Worf and Troy dr. crusher Geordi LaForge
Riker
I hate myself
[Music]
tonight
you said this show earlier Cheers yeah
never watched it not once it was okay I
was too little for it too I guess how
movie put our TV poster for once hmm
was on NBC
[__]
damnit I've seen that show give me a
hint guys
it was very difficult to find just that
yeah without him be like we roll it out
yeah
damn oh it doesn't sound the same when
you don't look at you're not looking at
the goatee mm-hmm
true facts facts only scared me
this American Horror Story skirt I'm
sorry for scaring you okay I don't know
if you watch the show at all either I
hope some of y'all watch it though [__]
Inspector Gadget yeah did you ever watch
yes it was so dead Inspector Gadget
really not like what I'm about to do
something like ridiculous I go go gadget
leg dude Inspector Gadget was so good I
love that show that like that woke up
the imagination it was really good
how many more my gosh just a few
[Music]
hey Soph yeah great job if you're
interested in like special effects
makeup great [__] show it's on sci-fi
we have probably have some seasons we
have been watched avoid and crippling
that was the one I used to snapchat
they're real and Hedrick was great great
great great
fast burgers
I really don't think you know this I put
this in here because I wanted to know if
anyone else watched this show or if it
with me and only me come through fam
[Music]
no no clue they already said the name of
the show a little while hold on
wasn't a very big animal in the deep
voice he said hey dude hey dude yeah we
show called hey dude I loved it sound
like some troll [__] yes hey dude maybe
it is familiar I've never watched a
table to play show hey dude where was
that con Nickelodeon hmm had to have
heard that name before
all right I got a skip give me one
second here you married at first sight
one two three four it's only nothing
it's all nothing such good song I love
it when you go to this song and even
you're like the song of most theme songs
on YouTube it's all the comments are
just like yeah is anyone else
[Music]
there's an autographed picture of this
man in our house right now it was a gift
given to me when I was younger
price is right yeah Bob Barker good also
stars in the hit Adam Sandler movie
happy gilmore that is true that is great
alright here's the last one you ended it
with this I just want you to see though
I didn't clip the regular theme I
clipped the cops opening but with the
office theme song over speeding and
crashing oh you ended it in the office
that's a that's a really sweet move of
you on Seinfeld but you just I love you
I love you thanks Julie thanks for
ending it in the office did you like
that I did I had fun was a fun game yeah
it made me watch it made me want to
watch all those things similar to the
the movie song podcast yeah we could do
more parts of these for sure yeah I mean
there's my god and I should do something
for you because this is a good one that
I could probably do for you 200 people
like watching my struggle hopefully you
played well at home definitely didn't
play as well as me though oh [__] good
thank you for doing the research yeah
and quizzing me I think you did really
well though you honestly you did better
than I thought you were gonna do that's
all I strive for just a little bit
better than expectations mostly okay
mm-hmm I never yell ready huh
what do we tell people to look up to
find that fine cuz it's my new favorite
behind that I didn't see when it was on
vine it's nice girl yeah farts and says
all right vine or something really I
don't [__] know I'm afraid to like
search the word fart though what do you
mean
wait oh my girl farts vine girl farts
YouTube yes literally its vine girl name
this girl in this purple wig she looks
over her shoulder turns back it's just
it doesn't do it justice like this girl
is singing and then farts and then turns
over just see me was watching and then
not only is she relieved when she turns
back she's just like kind of feeling it
anyway that's how I'm feeling right now
thank you guys for tuning in to another
episode of definitely podcast we
appreciate you so much you guys have a
wonderful week and we'll see you next
week
ya know your know your TV music okay
it'll help you later in life I promise
[Music]